you can also see the Mike Florio show
prior to this one on NBCSN and his
website it's the talk of the town it's
Pro Football Talk and Mike Florio joins
us now Mike how are you Dan doing great
buddy I like the new name for the show
the hell with Pro Football Talk live
Mike Florio show sounds a hell of a lot
better yeah thank you for approving that
change yes yes yes it should be it
should be it should be pro football talk
with Mike Florio or Mike Florio's pro
football talk I don't know the less I'm
involved in it by name maybe the more
people actually yeah but it's like much
The Tonight Show with Jay Leno or Johnny
Carson or the CBS Evening News with
Walter Cronkite that's what we're trying
to get for you Mike
that works oh I'll take that I'll take
that all right I got a few things here
the owners meetings what are what will
happen this week today at the owners
meetings well it's funny what they're
primarily doing they're addressing all
of the issues that were not resolved in
March when they took up as the first
order of business approving the Raiders
moved to Las Vegas and then got the hell
out of Arizona before anybody change
their mind or bothered to ask why are we
doing this so they've got some things
they need to deal with more than they
usually deal with in May the overtime
reduction from 15 minutes to 10 minutes
a rule change that was just forgotten
back in March the competition committee
had proposed to allow teams to hire
coaches whose current teams are still in
the postseason that's been like a joke
in recent years where Kyle Shanahan
everybody knew he was going to be the
49ers coach for example earlier this
year they want to potentially get rid of
that rule some other things floating
around like two players on injured
reserve who can come back in any given
year so some items that just got lost in
the cracks as they got out of Arizona as
quickly as they could back in late March
I had a couple of the things that I have
let me start with over time now we keep
tweaking it if it's supposed to be
reduced from 15 to 10 minutes because of
player safety why do we have overtime at
all I'm like well and you know what
that's a great point we have overtime
because people don't like ties but I
think that this move Dan is all about
one thing and one thing only taking off
of the table
one of the criticisms of short week
football because anytime it's explained
now the latest item at NFL comm the
league owned me up media platform and
there's been explanations like this from
people like Rich McKay the chair of the
competition committee they say we never
know when that team is going to play
again and they may be playing on a
Thursday night and I really do think
that this is all about not player safety
big picture this is about those very
rare occasions we saw last year Tampa
Bay played the Raiders nearly the full
75 minutes had to play Thursday night
against the Falcons when that happens
what's the consequence
guys like you guys like me others in the
media say here's a reason why maybe
Thursday Night Football isn't the best
thing for the NFL to do it bolsters the
arguments against it so you take away
one of the arguments against it by
reducing that maximum of 75 minutes down
to 70 minutes and I think that's what
this is all about eliminating ways that
people like us can complain about short
week football and also players
complaining about recovery time and
whatnot and that's what I think this is
so they're going to accept more ties you
have unintended consequences like a team
that wins the kickoff getting the ball
and slamming on the brakes and dinking
and dunking down the field and kicking a
field goal with one or two minutes left
on the clock or no time left on the
clock and that's why I think if they do
this they need to do it on an
experimental basis so they can see some
of those unintended consequences come to
fruition and celebrations are we are
going to loosen up lighten up a little
bit here that was another one damn that
got lost in the shuffle in March there
was a lot of talk in advance of the
meetings about what may or may not
change and then nothing changed and they
they claim they're going to change
something but I don't know what they're
going to do it's one thing to say hey
we're sick of being criticized for being
the know funnily when you're going to
change what we're going to do you
ultimately have to have a rule whatever
the rule is you have to have a rule and
it has to be consistently enforced and
I'm a firm believer you need to take the
officials out of it all together treat
it as something that a player would get
fined for if he does cross the line not
something where the official has to
decide in the heat of the moment do I
pull out the flag do an up pull up slide
you got 15 yards of field position
riding on that knee jerk decision you
got discretion that they now
expect the officials to exercise I say
get rid of the penalty altogether make
it a fine and and have a line in place
where the league office knows when they
look at the video whether or not the guy
crossed and if he did he gets a letter
on Tuesday saying that he's going to be
making an involuntary contribution to
the charity the NFL's choice he's Mike
Florio from pro football talk joining a
Stan Patrick Show Los Angeles and the
future of having a Super Bowl there is
what well here's the thing the stadium
construction has already been delayed by
a year and so now it opens in 2020 the
new stadium in Inglewood and that's the
year that it's supposed to host the
Super Bowl and do you really want and I
keep stepping back saying why are the LA
people pushing to keep the Super Bowl in
the first year of the operation of a new
stadium you got 20 games to be played
between the charges and the rams and
hovering over everything you do from the
moment you cut the ribbon on the place
you know you're finishing the year with
the Super Bowl why do you want to put
yourself through that kind of stress
just push it back for a year comply with
the league rule and I think the number
one reason Dan to insist on compliance
with that rule that you have to have
your stadium up and running for two
years before you host a Super Bowl
ensuring that all of your security
procedures are in place and that you can
properly secure the building for a Super
Bowl and let the right people in keep
the wrong people out ensure that nobody
is going to be able to slip anything
through any gate any opening any
weakness any crack you've got two full
years to get to the point where you're
confident that you can pull off a Super
Bowl that they should want to delay this
thing to the 2021 season I'm surprised
they don't yeah I agree with you because
you want to make sure you're having the
best product on display at the biggest
moment in your franchise history you're
hosting the Super Bowl they're the last
thing you it they almost feel like hey
if we don't have it in 2020 then we
never get it back the NFL is going to
reward you for everything that you've
done to have two teams relocate in Los
Angeles one other thing here with Tom
Brady is the Brady giselle concussion
story over I think it is because where
does it go from here Tom's going to keep
his mouth shut about it by the next time
he talked to the media probably
the week before the regular season
opener when we're up in Foxborough for
Chiefs Patriots he'll get asked about it
and he'll say that's old news that's
been addressed that's weeks ago and
we're focused on the upcoming season
that statement from Don Yee
even though it said nothing tom was not
diagnosed with a concussion whoa yeah
that's the problem he wasn't diagnosed
because he didn't get evaluated for a
concussion but that caused this thing to
get put to bed some media outlets
interpreted the statement as being he
didn't have a concussion which is
fundamentally different from he wasn't
diagnosed with a concussion it was a
masterstroke Tom found a way to tiptoe
through the minefield and now the next
time he addresses it will be the first
time he addresses it and he'll say it's
already been addressed yeah but it
hasn't been addressed and you could say
that to Brady no Tommen hasn't been did
you have a concussion not one diagnosed
did you have a concussion why did your
wife say you've had numerous concussions
including one last year I don't think
it's I don't think it's over it
shouldn't be well I I don't disagree
with that but you got to think about the
context for who be addressing it in a
press conference where it's a shotgun
approach where it's one reporter after
another how many times are you going to
be asked that same question and you're
going to have reporters who are going to
move on to the next topic now if it's a
one-on-one where an agreement isn't made
in advance that he's not just asked
about it that's a different story
altogether but you know how that game
yes that's true I don't saying that
about Brady I'm just saying that
generally there were our requests made
from time to time to avoid certain
topics and then you have to decide do I
agree to that or I just say screw it I'm
not doing the interview
yeah but you know Drew Brees coming on
the show and saying he wouldn't tell his
wife that he had a concussion I players
are doing their best to hide concussions
more now than they did you know 10 or 15
years ago because we weren't looking for
it as much now we're looking now you
really have to hide a concussion if
that's what your goal is and it's funny
Dan in the 2015 season when Ben
Roethlisberger tapped out of the game in
Seattle when no one knew he was dealing
with any concussion symptom that was
heralded as a sign the culture has truly
changed no no it's even an aberration
he's the one guy out of a thousand that
will do that just because one guy does
it doesn't
mean that anyone else is going to do it
these guys want to play and they know
that if you step off of the field and
the next man up comes in and does a good
job one thing leads to another and all
of a sudden you can't make the mortgage
payment on your house anymore and you
know you go get a real job for a living
so these guys are going to fight through
it at every level of football think
about an 18 year old well you knows
you're not going to play in the NFL but
you know what he's 18 and he wants to
play football he's gonna have health
problems when he's 63 so what he's 18
he's not thinking about that so that's
the problem because what you think about
all the things we hear that are good
about football overcoming adversity
working with teammates no pain no gain
it's counter to all of that to say I'm
sorry I I can't continue because I think
I may have concussion symptoms that's a
fundamental problem that's football
faces at every level and I think what
happened last week with Britt with Brady
is just the most recent example of it
thank you Mike it's Mike Florio's pro
football talk on NBCSN SCI touring Mike
Florio thank you Mike
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience